[Musique]
bienvenue à tous on va expirer inspirer
respirer de la poésie grâce à mon invité
et ma pujard bonjour c'est pas tous les
jours qu'on parle de poésie c'est assez
rare alors vous êtes vous-même actrice
mettons en scène on parlera d'ailleurs
d'un spectacle pour info que vous allez
mettre en scène et jouer bientôt mais là
vous venez pour un recueil de poésie
expirez inspiré qui est publié et nous
c'est eloédition
d'où vous vient
d'abord pour dire c'est absolument
magnifique
c'est vrai très très beau très beau
recueil de poésie d'où vous vient le
goût de la poésie
déjà merci beaucoup le goût de la poésie
me venir vraiment de l'enfance en fait
je pense que la poésie c'est avant tout
une ouverture au monde et une ouverture
à la beauté et
[Musique]
je pense qu'on est dans un monde qui est
rempli de beauté et
souvent les poètes qu'on ne voit pas ben
en tout cas souvent les poètes essaient
de voir un petit peu
l'invisible ou le difficilement des
solables je pense que ça fait partie de
notre art en tant que poète auteur et
plus largement artiste et donc du coup
c'est ça cette envie de faire de la
poésie mais vient vraiment depuis
l'enfance
d'exprimer la beauté d'exprimer
l'émotion et d'exprimer une forme de
complexité est-ce que dans votre
génération je crois que vous venez de la
verrière c'est ça
c'est quelque chose de partager la
poésie ou c'est quelque chose qui semble
très lointain
[Musique]
et ben écoutez je dirais que dans notre
génération la très récemment depuis
approximativement 5 ou 10 ans il y a un
vrai essor de la poésie puisqu'il y a
une vraie un vrai essor de la prise de
conscience et des réseaux sociaux
actuellement il y a beaucoup de réseaux
sociaux autour de la poésie je pense à
rubikor
Félix Radu les choses comme ça et donc
du coup la poésie est remise au goût du
jour et
devient plus accessible je trouve et
c'est vraiment intéressant ce qui se
passe actuellement d'un point de vue
littéraire
et
frais
une question difficile enfin laquelle
l'édifice de répondre mais comment on
écrit la poésie est-ce que ça parce que
qu'est-ce que c'est la poésie parfois on
dit c'est le c'est le sont plus que le
sens
c'est le mot c'est aussi ce que vous
disiez la vision que peut-être d'autres
n'ont pas
qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce que pour vous si
vous deviez définir ce que c'est la
poésie qu'est-ce que vous diriez
c'est compliqué
quelle belle et grande question
effectivement
pour moi la poésie
la beauté de de vert d'une image
parce que parfois c'était Jean-François
Revel je crois dans son anthologie de la
poésie qui disait on peut être poète par
un verre un seul verre ce qui est pas
faux
c'est absolument pas faux on peut voir
même les haïku ouvert
mais en trois verres parfois
et la poésie je pense que c'est un art
de l'évocation et
de donner de la force aux mots
c'est-à-dire de rassembler peu ou
énormément de mots il y a des très
longues poésies moi d'ailleurs dans ce
recueil il y a des poésies qui sont
assez longues
assembler les mots les façonner pour
qu'il révèle quelque chose
de profondément complexes et sensible
après c'est ma vision la poésie
il y a autant de poésies que de poète et
surtout autant de poésies que de
lecteurs mais quand vous écrivez un
poème il est dans votre tête comme ça ou
vous mettez à votre table de travail
comment est-ce qu'il y a un rituel
est-ce que comment ça se passe alors il
y a différents modes d'écriture pour moi
donc il y a un premier mode qui souvent
est
un mode lâcher prise écriture
automatique ou
j'écris je noircis le cahier quoi et j'y
vais j'y vais j'y vais et
on sort une matière un petit peu informe
très brut mais qui a son sens
et par la suite cette matière très brute
et ben je la façonne je la polie comme
ça
on pourrait parler d'une peinture de la
même façon que vous parlez de la poésie
et il y a des liens forcément mais bien
sûr c'est de la création mais justement
poésie si on prend son étymologie c'est
poésie ça vient de de créer fabriquer
construire en fait étymologiquement et
la poésie c'est en fait qu'est-ce que
c'est c'est de la création et c'est pour
ça que c'est parfois même plus large que
les mots et lorsqu'on lorsqu'on crée un
poème c'est le façonner le parfaire et
ils mettent autant de soi qui met une
forme de d'universalité d'accord d'après
moi en tout cas
ce sont deux exercices extrêmement
différents alors écrire pour la poésie
écrire pour le théâtre
oui
en tout cas vu que à la base j'écris
plus pour le théâtre
cette dimension là nourrit beaucoup ma
poésie dans le sens où mes poèmes
évoquent souvent des personnages et
sont souvent écrits pour être lu au
moins dans la tête d'accord avec vous
savez on a toutes
une petite voix dans la tête qui lit les
textes et j'essaye que cette petite voix
soit vraiment
au service du rythme dans ma poésie
d'accord oui parce que le rythme est
fondamental on met beaucoup de choix
dans une poésie dans un texte oui
inévitablement on met beaucoup de soi
dans dans un texte
la poésie c'est souvent associé à
l'intime
moi je sais beaucoup d'écrire des textes
engagés des textes tournés vers le monde
il y a toute une partie qui s'appelle
s'inspirer et qui s'inspire
qui s'inspire de personnalités
inspirantes
et malgré tout ces personnalités sont
inspirantes pour moi et
c'est une affaire de résonance en fait
et
dans les cris d'un poète quel qu'il soit
il y a toujours la part la plus profonde
de son intimité
alors le recueil s'appelle expirer
inspirer vous dites dans la préface tout
ça c'est respirer on va respirer la
poésie et vous commencez en disant
respirer cette inconscient mais
primordial évidemment sinon il y a pas
si on son respiration il y a pas de il y
a pas de vie effectivement possible
mais c'est vrai que la respiration il y
a en effet c'est de temps il y a mon
expire le monde inspire expirez alors
c'est quoi c'est c'est
rentrer en soi-même ou aller vers les
autres
respirer expirez expirez
on donne de soi on donne de ce soir
c'est tout lâcher tout extérioriser donc
c'est
aller vers les autres mais en partant
profondément du soi
et donc
une fois les poumons vides et le cœur
léger le temps est venu de retourner
vers le monde et de s'inspirer c'est à
dire que d'abord voilà il faut savoir
qui on est où on est oui
de savoir où on va quoi en gros oui ben
en fait c'est un recueil qui a une
dimension très consciente je me suis
beaucoup inspirée de la méditation ou
bah on va faire le vide lâcher expirer
les tensions etc pour ensuite
inspiré de l'énergie inspirer parce
qu'on a envie de mettre en soi et donc
vraiment ce recueil est vraiment
construit avec l'énergie de l'air qu'on
respire et vous dites aussi qui a
travers ce recueil vous prenez
la fusion de l'individu et du monde
c'est bien ça veut dire que expirez
voilà c'est l'individu et puis inspirer
c'est aussi regarder le monde et
regarder ce qui est beau dans le monde
qui vous entoure c'est ça oui oui
effectivement
j'aime beaucoup les paradoxes et je
parle souvent de complexité et en fait
ce que j'aime dans l'écriture c'est
quand on va de l'infiniment petit vers
l'infiniment grand et donc de thèmes
infiniment
intime personnel complètement privé et
puis qui en fait à travers l'écriture
peuvent se déployer et prendre une
ampleur qui nous touche tous ou du moins
presque tous Voilà c'est vraiment
l'objectif de certains de ces poèmes
l'univers c'est l'université
en parlant de soi on touche parfois à
l'universel c'est un peu ça et en tout
en touchant l'universel on parle souvent
de soi est-ce que on va après regarder
quelques quelques un texte puis vous
allez faire plaisir dans Lire
quelques-uns mais vous en dire quelques
uns c'est pas
mais d'abord vous disiez c'est vrai
qu'il y a un retour regarde la poésie
mais c'est facile de de trouver un
éditeur qui publie de la poésie
[Musique]
j'ai pas j'ai pas eu trop de Malte
honnêtement j'ai eu de la chance et
toqué à la bonne porte au bon moment
c'est comme ça que ça se passe dans la
vie mais en tout cas c'est moins facile
d'éditer et de promouvoir de la poésie
je pense
que
un roman peut-être je ne sais pas de
policiers ou de fantaisie qui sont plus
combien de milliers de romans qui se
publient des recueils de poésie je pense
qu'il y en a malheureusement
un peu moins malheureusement parce que
heureusement on ne publie pas de tout et
n'importe quoi
il y a déjà
une sélection une sélection qui se fait
mais c'est vrai que c'est vrai que c'est
c'est vrai que c'est souvent des petits
tirages pour la poésie enfin
malheureusement alors que autrefois
c'était c'était un art très populaire
justement je vous interroger là-dessus
certains disent aujourd'hui mais le
la poésie
c'est un arbre populaire mais elle était
remplacée par la chanson est-ce que vous
êtes d'accord avec ça
c'est vrai fou moi mon avis mais je
partage pleinement votre point de vue
effectivement
la poésie a beaucoup de nourri la
chanson
et la chanson s'inspire de la poésie et
on peut dire qu'une part de la nouvelle
poésie est dans certains certaines
chansons même les sorts durable dans les
années 90
mais plus ou moins bien à la poésie en
effet oui
donc c'est vraiment dans cet essence là
après ça reste pour moi de choses
un peu différentes sans faire de
classement de valeur parce que
tu détestent comme ça et puis qu'on
brasse le chant ça peut être très beau
aussi enfin donc oui parce que ces deux
écritures différentes
mais il y a des textes dans dans expirer
inspiré il y a un texte notamment que
vous on peut chanter que vous chantez
là parce que je sais que vous avez un
petit un petit problème donc on va pas
vous n'avez pas je vais pas vous
demander de le chanter ici mais il y en
a un
oui il y a une conscience que en fait
j'ai adapté dans un spectacle il y a un
mois j'ai joué un spectacle
en partie inspirée de ce recueil du
recueil d'un collègue et amis Anthony
vanderlan et du coup il y a un des
poèmes que j'ai adapté sous forme de
chanson d'accord c'est vrai que ça s'y
prête puisque les rimes sont déjà
présentes la musicalité de la poésie
en général là et donc le prolongement du
travail vers la musicalité est assez
facile effectivement puisque vous êtes
mettez en scène des comédiennes est-ce
que est-ce que
expirez inspirer ça pourrait devenir en
effet un spectacle
[Musique]
ça pourrait le devenir en soi
là récemment j'ai fait un spectacle du
coup inspiré de ce recueil avec certains
de ces poèmes et les poèmes de mon
collègue
et là mon envie c'est pas forcément d'en
faire un spectacle après des mises en
voix sous forme de lecture théâtralisée
pour moi c'est un art qui est aussi
important à lire qu'à écouter ce qu'on
en a pas du tout le même ressenti en
fait absolument c'est pas la même chose
quand on lit quand on entend est-ce que
la poésie enfin moi c'est vrai que en
tant que lectrice de poésie c'est
vraiment un art que j'associe à mon lit
un petit un petit thé et puis un petit
sourire quoi et voir parfois quelques
larmes parce que c'est
bah c'est voilà c'est un tendance
d'introspection d'émotion et de
découverte aussi d'un univers alors que
quand on se fait lire un poème
là c'est un temps de réception qui est
vraiment différent ou on va plus être
ébranlée par la personne et savoir
sa façon de dire les choses etc quels
sont les poètes qui vous inspirent
justement alors les potes qui
m'inspirent il y en a beaucoup il y a
bien évidemment Charles Baudelaire qui
est un peu des premières sources
d'inspiration de nombreux poètes pour
son la beauté de sévère il y a également
Maya
qui est une autrice allemande métissée
et qui parle beaucoup de féministes de
son identité de lutte antiracisme
je trouve ça vraiment très inspirant
comme auteur féminine oui c'est la
preuve que la poésie aussi c'est pas
c'est la beauté évidemment mais c'est
aussi c'est aussi une pensée ça peut
être aussi une pensée ça peut être aussi
quelque chose qui agit sur sur nos
sociétés enfin qui témoignent de
des questions qui traversent nos
sociétés oui la poésie c'est un art
profondément percutant et qui quand il
est utilisé comme outil de plaidoyer est
très efficace et encore aujourd'hui
alors
voilà ce qu'on a dit on va pénétrer un
peu dans ce recueil c'est difficile de
le faire comme ça vous avez accepté de
dire un certain nombre de
trois textes
on va commencer avec celui qui ouvre le
recueil respire moi
respire avec moi
et bien écoutez c'est avec grand plaisir
c'est si simple
c'est un cercle continu
j'inspire je prends
j'expire je rends
et la boucle reprend
à chaque inspire un nouveau présent
un futur souvenir
j'ai inspiré
l'odeur de Paris au mille couleurs et
ses pots d'échappement
les cierges évanescents et les volutes
de l'encens
le paradoxe des amours acidulés le suc
des fleurs du paradis
le fumet des idées la sueur de front et
les livres vieillis
les rosés de petrichor à l'aube égorgé
de promesses au soleil levant
les relents du désespoir et l'écume des
pleurs insouciants
à chaque expire un souffle transformé
un nouveau passé
j'ai expiré des mots des formes pensées
en mouvement
la première partie de ce recueil s'est
rempli gaiement
de secret
de rêves parfois spirituels
mes mots noirs sont couchés sur le
papier blanc
je veux que tu les sentes que tu les
inspires je veux que tu les déformes que
tu les soupires
donne-leur les couleurs de tes habits et
de ton Firma
laisse à mes mots la liberté d'être
vivant
j'ai aspiré
à un nouvel élan
un nouvel inspire
un air plus grand 9
loin de mes soupirs
la deuxième partie de ce recueil est
faite d'inspiration
j'espère que tu y trouveras de la joie
et du réconfort
j'y ai trouvé l'envie de me battre et
d'expirer encore
merci beaucoup
j'ai juste je
remarque
peut-être un mot qui veut expliquer ces
pétrichor c'est cette odeur du matin
[Musique]
mouillée enfin
ce que dégage les plantes lors de la
rosée du matin c'est eau de la rosée du
matin c'est le pétrichor
qui m'a fait penser c'est vrai que c'est
j'ai inspiré l'odeur de Paris au mille
couleurs et ses pots d'échappement ça me
fait penser à peu Apollinaire quand la
Tour Eiffel c'est vrai oui c'est vrai
parce que ça prouve que la poésie c'est
c'est alors comme ça petricor c'est en
effet un mot un peu savant mais il y a
les pots d'échappement c'est il y a la
réalité il y a le il y a le quotidien
aussi qui est c'est beau bravo merci
beaucoup
on en dit un autre et bien allons-y
alors je crois que c'est l'amour
terrestre un amour terrien alors ça
c'est on est dans le on est toujours
dans expiré
là on est toujours dans expirer oui
le premier le premier poème que vous
venez de dire il expose au fond
le premier poème ni dans l'expérience
dans la série
c'est la présentation
et donc du coup nous allons enchaîner
sur l'amour terrestre un amour terrien
as-tu déjà eu le courage
d'essayer encore
de fermer les yeux
d'éteindre ton ego douloureux
de plonger vers d'autres paysages
as-tu déjà eu le courage
d'imaginer ce qui brûle en moi
car sous mon ventes règne un feu pour
toi
noyau de Lumière et d'Amour sauvage
as-tu déjà eu le courage d'imaginer
l'étendue de mon amour
depuis le noyau
jusqu'aux infinies paysages
mon amour est
océan rivière cascade
lave sacrée
glacier cristallin falaise libertaire
colline pleine
dénivelée aventures harmonieux
infinité de choix entre mes courbes et
mes lignes pour te relier aux cieux
arbre flamboyant
cerisier rosé
saule pleureur au gré du vent chêne
libre
baobab être majestueux
fleur douce
père au flux suave effluves entêtant
parsemés dans les
parmi l'oxygène éthérée
saveur inopinées
fraîche
acidulée sucré
souviens-toi du charme de mes fruits
défendus
paradisiaque et passionnés
as-tu déjà eu le courage
d'ouvrir les yeux
te réaliser l'étendue de ton carnage
littoraux à sécher
forêt mutiler
fruit du Paradis devenu poison de
plastique
et mon sol a siéger recouvert de
frontières
mais entrailles est rentrées pour tes
bijoux de l'eau
et mon or noir que tu taches de sang
as-tu déjà eu le courage
de penser à tes frères qui me parcourent
à la nage
ils espèrent que mes richesse se
partagent
et tu ne leur réponds qu'avec des
frontières et des cages
as-tu déjà eu le courage
de ressentir mon amour sage
depuis tes racines ton corps
l'éternel instant
l'infini
il n'en reste que des morts et des
débris
moi mon amour
c'est mon courage
invincible et omniprésent
malgré mes quelques tempêtes et
tremblements
je peux te pardonner tout tes outrages
je suis bien plus qu'une grosse boule
bleue
reconnais moi
je suis essentielle
je suis la vie la nature et ses mystères
je suis la terre mais
toi
qu'est-ce que ton amour sans tes rêves
terrestre est à condition d'erreur
céleste
c'est rien
sans moi tu n'es rien
pourtant tu me délaisse
bienheureux cruel
as-tu le courage de laisser résonner ma
prière
bravo on disait tout à l'heure que oui
la poésie c'était aussi
une façon de parler du temps présent et
là on y est on est dans le dans la
Bataille pour la Terre pour l'écologie
contre le réchauffement climatique pour
toutes les grandes batailles qui se
jouent aujourd'hui l'avenir de
l'humanité c'est très beau bravo merci
beaucoup oui c'est
alors on avait prévu en troisième
malheureusement on a plus le temps
au recueil expiré inspiré c'est donc
c'est éloédition et c'est donc Emma puja
je voulais signaler aussi puisque vous
êtes vous êtes aussi autrice et
de théâtre que vous vous êtes vous
faites partie d'un collectif qui
s'appelle le collectif dans la peau oui
effectivement je fais partie du
collectif dans la peau qui est
une troupe de théâtre
yvelinoise à Saint-Germain-en-Laye
effectivement et vous allez jouer un
spectacle pour le jeune public que vous
avez écrit qui s'appelle notre pays des
merveilles donc inspiré de la liste de
Carole et ça sera au théâtre Clavel à
Paris c'est tous les dimanches en avril
Léon mai c'est ça à 15h tous les
dimanches du mois d'avril et mai à
partir de 15 heures on est au théâtre
Clavel donc plein centre parisien on est
très contents et donc voilà on a très
hâte c'est un spectacle est très
poétique lui aussi qui est vraiment
entre le jeune public et le taux publics
familial donc avec le collectif dans la
peau on est très heureux de jouer de
jouer ce spectacle et on entre en
résidence de création à la salle Jacques
Tati à Saint-Germain-en-Laye d'accord
quelques textes ben oui avec merci
beaucoup Emma pizza merci à vous pour
votre accueil merci
[Musique]